bonjour christian de boissieu merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france le fonds
de solidarité prendra donc fin le 30
septembre d'un côté il ya ceux qui
disent il ya plus d'argent dans les
caisses la dette s'alourdit de l'autre
il ya les partisans de l'état providence
où se situe le juste milieu
j'allais dire en diaries progressivement
juste milieu et c'est à dire que on est
en train de remettre en cause
progressivement le point qu'il en coûte
après avoir dépensé beaucoup d'argent
mais je pense qu'il fallait le faire il
fallait faire pour éviter la montée du
chômage pour éviter les faillites
d'entreprises et c'est bon mais ça ne
peut pas durer éternellement donc
progressivement on retire le tapis sous
les pieds si je puis hier de l'économie
tout en maintenant un soutien dans les
secteurs qui sont fermées ou encore très
contraint donc on essaye de trouver ce
juste milieu et je pense que le à
quelques mois de la présidentielle la
question est centrale pour le
gouvernement parce qu'il veut il faut
éviter montée du chômage il faut éviter
une montée un développement des
faillites un parti mais du côté du côté
des pme et en même temps on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça à financer j'allais
dire non pas à fonds perdus mais sur une
grande échelle à financer l'économie
justement quels seront les impacts de
cette décision sur les mois à venir pour
les entreprises des secteurs concernés
est ce que cette décision ne risque pas
d'engendrer un rebond des fermetures
justement d'établissement des faillites
comme vous venez de le dire et à terme
de freiner la croissance économique il
ya ce risque je pense c'est la raison
pour laquelle monsieur le maire tout en
visant le fonds de solidarité va prendre
fin
à la fin de septembre annonce qu'il va y
avoir un autre dispositif - général plus
spécifiques au cas par cas qui va en
classe donc je pense que le plan de la
république et le gouvernement essaye de
trouver cette ligne de crête qui est pas
évident entre d'un côté
montré qu' on est très sensible à
l'argent public et qu'il faut sans doute
arrêter ce déversement sans limite d'âge
jean public et de l'autre éviter
absolument à quelques mois de la
présidentielle les montées de chômage
qui a baissé nous sommes à 8 % au
chauffeur on a retrouvé le niveau
d'avant la crise il était également un
développement des faillites
d'entreprises en particulier dans le
tissu des pme parce que les pme par
définition sont a priori plus fragiles
que les grosses justement vous parlez
des pm les petites et moyennes
entreprises quels seront les critères
pour évaluer les entreprises qui vont
continuer à bénéficier de cette aide au
cas par cas en parlant des pme ce qui
est pas une d'icône une dichotomie au
final dans toute cette histoire entre
les pme les petites et moyennes
entreprises et les grands groupes du cac
écoutez moi j'ai écouté la déclaration
du ministre des finances ou non le maire
ce matin sur france inter et au fond il
a appelé à ce qu'ils appellent une
solidarité le long le long des filières
de production celui arrêté entre les
grandes et les petits bonds et vous y
croyez à ça 1 vous y croyez à ça cette
solidarité
c'est pas gagné parce qu' il peut y
avoir des intérêts divergents et que par
exemple quand on regarde l'évolution de
ce qu'on appelle les dettes
interentreprises d'aider les clients les
délais fournisseurs ce qui est bon il
peut être bon pour les grandes
entreprises peut être moins bons pour
l'épée mais on coeur de gestion créer de
riz donc je répète ça n'est pas gagné
moi je considère que le risque de montée
du chômage et de développement des
faillites en pas qu et d'un tissu des
pme que ce riche il est encore devant
nous et que tout va dépendre du doigté
avec lequel le gouvernement va
progressivement
remettre en cause et le poids qu'il en
coûte qui est en place depuis mars 2020
bruno le maire a estimé la semaine
dernière que l'économie donc redémarré
il a évoqué des perspectives de
croissance à 6% se réalise que c'est
utopique non syrie à lui si vous voulez
comme dernière la france était à -1 8,2
-8 2 une landes récession quand vous
touchez le fond de la piscine comment
l'affairé asnières c'est normal de
rebondir donc le 6 %
c'est pas un exploit il ya beaucoup de
rattrapage de côté consommation du côté
de l'investissement ce qui va être le
test c'est plutôt la croissance de
l'année prochaine et 2023 c'est à dire
que faire fi 6% en 2021
c'est sympathique ça va servir l'emploi
et comme vous savez il ya des secteurs
qui sont en pénurie de main d'oeuvre à
côté à côté de situations d'accueil
encore pas mal de beaucoup trop de
chômeurs mais pour moi le test de la
croissance française s'est pas cette
année quand elle faire c'est en 2022
2023 quand on sortira de la crise
sanitaire et qu'on trouvera nos
perspectives de croissance fondamental
également nos problèmes de fond de
l'économie française le fait qu' ils
font 16 n'a pas fait aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de réformes structurelles
il sera encore devant nous
justement ces réformes de l'économie
française
que vous évoquez elles sont devant nous
est ce qu'elles vont être encore devant
nous à terme plus tard parce qu'on sait
qu'il va y avoir la présidentielle il ya
peut-être des dossiers qui vont être
remis sous le tapis et non moi je pense
que la réforme des retraites est pour
l'essentiel
remise pour l'après présidentielle
c'est-à-dire après avis avril mais
2022 alors je sais que le présent et
gouvernement évoqué la possibilité
d'ouvrir les concertations à nouveau sur
la question de la réforme des retraites
et très franchement
je pense que dans ce contexte social
compliqué
je disais le chômage a baissé mais ils
pointent loin ces questions d'emploi des
jeunes alors le gouvernement prépare des
mesures
spécifiques pour les jeunes pour
l'entrée sud et les jeunes dans des
formations sur marché du travail n'est
situation sociale va être compliqué et
dans ce contexte la jument zune
également va être prudent daou ouvrir de
nouveaux fronts sociaux donc la réforme
des retraites pour l'essentiel à
montmédy ça va pousser à première
présidentielle vraiment effrayant vont
essayer de mettre en oeuvre ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est à dire réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui vous font
peut-être la dernière grande réforme de
ceux de ce mandat de ce quinquennat mac
ronde qui n'est pas terminée merci très
boissieu d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le vice
président du cercle des économistes